à l'occasion des défilés de mode
récemment encore on a pu observer à la
dérobée le travail des photographes dont
le métier consiste à mettre au maximum
en valeur les modèles présentés et les
mannequins et qui les portent ensuite
viendra la séance photos pour les
magazines spécialisés comme le
prestigieux vogue et il faut savoir que
ces photographes sont de véritables
stars dans leur domaine c'est le cas
vous allez le voir de l'allemand petter
lindbergh que nous suivons au cours
d'une séance de pose reportage ce film
est zen pascal puis
l'oeil dans ce
conflit d'émotions natalia la russe
offre devant l'objectif de peter
lindbergh
séance de pause dans un atelier de
peintre caché derrière la bastille
instant magique le photographe et son
modèle s'abandonne dans un corps à corps
presque érotique hypnotique une danse
nuptiale
ça y est la photo est dans la boîte
toujours bien de les laisser un tout
petit peu perdues non c'est les sticks
trop bien ils essaient de faire trop
bien
et lundi deux trois mots ont montré des
photos un peu d'ambiance
ses mots
et après ils ont un grand espace pour
pour donner quelque chose
lèvres salies cheveux ébouriffés huilé
la peau est noirci à la cendre une
atmosphère suggéré par touches
impressionnistes
peu importe si sur les clichés on ne
saisit pas le détail le seul but de ce
cérémonial que les mannequins se sont
investis d'un rôle
aujourd'hui elle danse pour pina bausch
la chorégraphe allemande ou en tout cas
elle se l'imaginent
peter lindbergh est l'un des
photographes les plus sollicités du
moment son style lumière naturelle
cadrage des cinémas souvent servi par le
noir et blanc deux photographes de mode
qui disent les enfants des heures de vol
parce que les autres photographes se
voit des dix
artistes
finalement la mode peter lindbergh ne
s'en soucie guère ce qui l'intéresse
immortalisé une certaine idée de la
femme voler un souffle de mystère
dans quelques uns